[Music]
welcome to 3abn today Bible Q&A my name
is JD Quinn I'll be your host we got a
great team here today then the table for
me is Daniel parin welcome Daniel thank
you it's good to be here and one thing
I've learned from studying the Bible is
that there is no shortage of Bible
questions which is a good thing if you
got Bible questions amen drives you back
to the word of God amen amen next is Ian
Vander volt thank you in it's always
good to see you always good to see you
too JD thank you for having me thank you
thank you and then to my right is our
beautiful Shelley Quinn welcome Shelley
Quin you're not Prejudice at all are you
honey we just want to thank you all for
sending in your Bible questions because
it's our pleasure to actually study
these out and provide answers from
scripture for you want to tell you how
you can get in touch with us now this is
very very important because these are
your questions we get to enjoy the
questions that you send in there's three
ways that you can send these questions
in number one is if you'd like to text
them 618 228
3975 once again 618 228
3975 the second way is by email and
that's Bible QA at 3ab
bn. once again Bible QA 3abn .tv and the
last way to send them in is by Instagram
and that's at
3abn uncore official Once Again
3abn uncore
official once again thank you for being
here let's start this off by going and
have a word of prayer father we come to
you today in the name of Jesus we thank
you Lord for this opportunity to get
into the word father we love getting
into the word and we just ask Lord that
you be with each person that's watching
we ask Lord that you be with our panel
father thatth they will be able to abide
the Holy Spirit and father that they
will be able to make this a win-win a
win on our side and a win on those that
are watching we love you we thank you we
give you all praise and glory in the
name of Jesus amen amen amen
amen Daniel we're going to start with
you
we want to give you the first question
and uh most of these questions are two
minute three minute or four minute
questions so got to say a lot in a short
time why is classical music touted as
being okay many of the Great musicians
back then were members of secret
societies and this is from noene in
Trinidad in
Tobago all right nolene this is one of
those practical Christianity practical
living question questions which are
important how do we put into practice
the things that we find in God's word
and thinking about music we might
approve of some music because it's
beautiful or it's artistic or melodic or
it sounds like something that could be
used in church and sometimes we just
think it's good because it's old and if
it's old music it must be good and and
may maybe it is I I don't know you have
to evaluate each song individually but
real really the question is what music
does God approve of what would God have
us to listen to what would god what kind
of music would God have us to make with
instruments or with ourselves and
there's a number of principles that you
can find embedded in the Bible because
you're not going to find hard and fast
rules about what music or what tempo or
anything like that but uh 1 Corinthians
10:31 I love this principle and you can
apply it to music in many areas of your
life and it simply says whatever you do
do all to the glory of God and so you
ask yourself does this glorify God not
not could it glorify God if I put it in
the right setting or if I imagine the
right thoughts or words to it does it
actually glorify God which means we have
to evaluate music from God's perspective
and we have to ask for divine wisdom to
do that because music often times has a
backstory there's some reason why it
came into existence which you refer to
in this question some classical music
actually is inspired by Pagan Concepts
like like Druid worship or Roman and
Greek gods or Celestial worship and you
can sometimes tell that by the titles
and but it might be in a foreign
language you don't know sometimes
classical music tells Bible stories in a
way that distorts Bible truth you might
know that some classical music deals
with themes like alcohol and drugs and
intemperance with a beautiful Melody
some classical music is operas and
ballets or overtures where it's kind of
easier to evaluate them because usually
there's words or there's some kind of
title that says something about it or
sometimes they'll be based on previous
stories like Shakespeare's plays or
ancient mythology neither of which
honestly glorify God so music was
intended for worldly purposes like
dances and festivals that glorify
Humanity some music was written under
the influence of alcohol or drugs which
means that it was written under the
influence of Satan some music was
written by people whose lives were lived
in opposition to God and they spread
their philosophy of opposition to God
through their music it's kind of hard to
figure all these things out and so we
simply say Lord teach me and be willing
to submit our desires to God be willing
to surrender our appetite for music
because as we ask him and as we study
and learn God will reveal to us music
that does or does not glorify him Satan
uh we know in heaven Lucifer was a
musician and he knows that music is a
subtle tool to get to people's hearts
and so we need to be willing to
recognize and say I may have grown up
loving this but Lord if you want me to
set it aside I will sacrifice it because
I love you more amen great answer Ian
your first question can you please
explain Matthew
1112 11 verse2 and this is from Colorado
all right so for the person in Colorado
who texted this in thank you uh now I
will have you know that there are
multiple explanations for this verse but
I have found one to be consistent with
scripture and now at first glance you
also may think while reading this verse
that it might have a negative
connotation but let's go ahead and read
Matthew 11:2 and I'm reading from the
King James version and it says and from
the days of John the Baptist until now
the Kingdom of Heaven suffereth violence
and the violent take it by force now one
thing that you need to know is during
the times of John the Baptist there was
really religious apathy and what he
brought was an excitement he kind of
stirred things up against
by the you know hailing in the coming of
the Messiah and saying repent for the
Kingdom of Heaven is at hand but another
thing that you need to realize while
trying to figure out this verse is
something that we actually teach in our
3bn school discipleship in our Bible 101
class so what we're going to do is take
this verse and break it out into three
different sections the first is going to
be and from the days of John the Baptist
until now the Kingdom of Heaven
suffereth violence that will be section
one section two and the violent and
section three take it by force now when
you actually break this down and do a
word study on it you're going to find
that suffereth violence means to be
forced and the violent means energetic
and take it by force means to seize so
when you uh use this and you kind of
break it down into layman's terms and
and plug that in there it will say in
the days from John the Baptist until now
the Kingdom of Heaven is to be forced
and the energetic sees it now think
about that the Kingdom of Heaven is not
something that is passably obtained when
we give our lives over to Christ we
struggle we have things that we battle
with our thoughts our flesh our desires
uh our mind how our Behavior how we
treat others and what this verse is
really telling us is that the Kingdom of
Heaven it requires effort and those who
are passionate will take hold of it
right we strive we wrestle in this
Christian walk we have to fight we
agonize to subdue ourselves and to
subdue self and uh what you'll also see
the same concept of this struggle and
how have to fight for the Kingdom of
Heaven throughout scripture we'll read
in Luke 13: 24 that says strive to enter
through the narrow gate for many I say
to you will seek to enter enter and will
not be able that word strive means to
struggle to contend with an adversary to
fight to labor we see also in Paul with
his uh letter to Timothy in 1 Timothy
6:12 he says fight the good fight of
faith and lay hold onto eternal life we
read again in uh Ephesians chapter 6
says for we do not wrestle against flesh
and blood but against principalities
against Powers against the rulers of the
darkness of this age so you're seeing
this concept over and over and over
again uh also in Romans 8 and: 13 we
read for if you live according to the
flesh you will die but if by the spirit
you put to death the Deeds of the body
and you will live putting to death that
means to actually to kill the flesh we
you think about our own struggles in
life um you know with our own sins
things that maybe we have cultivated or
things that we've had even before
becoming a Christian that even when we
give our hearts over to God we struggle
with them and we have to fight for this
it's not you know there are things in
our lives that God immediately takes
away but there's others that we have to
learn to trust in him and to help him
with it we also you can look in Genesis
CH 32 jeck Jacob wrestles with God until
the break of day and says I will not or
I will not let you go unless you bless
me so really our Earnest and determined
effort in faith in Christ is that we
overcome and gain the kingdom of heaven
so just as time was short during the
time of uh John the Baptist time right
now is short for the second coming of
Christ so may God help those who have
heard the warning message to remember
that the Kingdom of Heaven suffereth
violence and the violent take it by
force amen great answer Shelly your
first question where does our Soul go
when it goes back to God and what does
he do with it and this is from Kelly in
Michigan well Kelly I'm going to give
you a little word original word study
first because it will be very beneficial
to us in the Hebrew there is a word
called ruach and the equivalent is is u
in the New Testament in the Greek is
Numa ruach and Numa are
translated Spirit breath breath of life
or wind so there's various translations
for that also in the Hebrew there is a
word nefes and in the Greek its
equivalent is Suk and that is a soul
that's how it's translated it means a
living breathing being a human or an
animal when it's an individual soul so
let's look at Genesis 2:7 at the time of
creation we see both ruach and uh neish
used here in Genesis 27 what we're going
to see is a Formula a body plus the
Breath of Life equals a soul it Genesis
2:7 the Lord formed man of the Dust of
the ground and he breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life that is the
word for Spirit also ruach he breathed
into the man the breath of life and Man
became a living Soul a neish so a soul
is a breathing
being so what we see here is the body of
Flesh plus that Divine spark of life
when God breathe the breath of life into
man which is the spirit they became body
plus Spirit equals a living being a soul
a neish that is unique from all others
so Adam was not given a soul he became a
soul he came into existence in Genesis
every time a baby or an animal is formed
that new life when it comes into
existence the Bible refers to them as
Souls Genesis 1:20 says let the waters
abound with abundance of living
creatures that's Souls that's neish and
it literally means let the waters swarm
or literal translation let the water
swarm swarms of Souls of life it's just
talking about the individuals of lot so
the soul is not a component or part of
the individual the soul soul is the
individual people and animals don't have
a soul they are souls so at death the
reverse takes place Ecclesiastes 12:7
the body minus the breath of
life you're not you're dead then shall
the dust out of which man made God's uh
which God made man's body dust will
return to the Earth as it was and the
spirit the ruach the Breath of Life
returns to God who gave it so we see
that the body minus that Breath of Life
you don't exist any longer but I want to
say one quick thing and I know I'm out
of time here but technically anyone
who's not breathing is not a living
being obviously or is not a soul but
when you cease to exist as a soul there
you still exist in a DNA record you know
only God can wipe out the history of
your existence and that's what Matthew
10:28 when Jesus said don't fear Those
Who Kill the body but can't kill the
soul rather fear Him who's able to
destroy both soul and body and hell so
death is like a sleeping existence and
you're resting that DNA you it it it
you're not going to come forth again
until the resurrection amen
good answer I hope that made sense yes
Daniel your second question what does
the Bible say about the Alfred vigner
continental drift theory this is all the
way from India all right from India and
I know there are those watching or
listening wondering what is the Alfred
vigner continental drift theory this
question is probably going out to just a
few but for the few of you who are
interested let's find out because
geology is a very exciting subject why
because the Earth is the Lords and we
want to know more about it and how it
came to be now of course the modern
vocabulary that would say things like
continental drift was not used during
the times of scripture but the Bible
does shed some light on this in 1912
Alfred Vagner who was uh a weatherman or
he studied weather and geology he
formally put together and expressed some
ideas that had already been expressed
before and the theory goes something
like this that long long ago all of the
the habitable continents of the world
were gathered together into a super
continent that was referred to or that
we is now referred to as Pangia Greek
word meaning all the lands and then
about 200 million years ago that Pangia
supercontinent began to break apart and
the pieces drift slowly slowly slowly
until they settled into their positions
where they currently are changing a
little bit uh through that time well
that was an early early way of looking
at the Modern the the placement of
modern continents today scientists use
something called the tectonic plate
Theory to understand how there is some
potential movement in continents and
other factors are involved as well now
the Bible timeline says this the
habitable space of the Earth was created
by God about 6,000 years ago and so you
can see some very very clear differences
between the 200 mil million year ancient
time frame and 6,000 years fairly
recently
and so the continental drift theory uh
just does not fit with the Bible story
and then Genesis 7 tells us that
convulsions of the earth during the
flood uh in Genesis 7:1 it describes it
like this The Fountains of the great
deep broke were broken up and the
windows of Heaven were opened and the wa
the Earth was completely covered with
water and the face of the Earth was you
know broken up by by stuff coming out
from inside the earth and so when the
waters receded the the land masses were
developed in such a way that what we
have now was established there uh in in
the receding of The Waters at the flood
ultimately God sets the bounds of the
earth and he sets the land masses in
their positions not a million-year
process of chance movements I'll just
give you one text here but there's many
we could find Through the Bible that say
things like Jeremiah
5:22 do not do you not fear me says the
Lord will you not tremble at my presence
who have placed the sand as the bound of
the Sea by a Perpetual decree that it
cannot go beyond it other words God sets
the boundaries of the land not some
process that has taken many many many
many years God is in charge amen
wow uh
Ian I've heard it said that all the
souls that are redeemed and are Apostles
will judge us all at the end of time I
thought Jesus was to do that it would be
so unfair to be judged by other people
because some may want to condemn us
where in the Bible is this and can you
elaborate on whether it's true or not
all right well uh I'm just going to jump
right into this because I'm going to try
and cram everything I know within this
next couple of minutes but in order to
understand who or way or who or what is
taking place uh at the end of time
regarding judgment we need to have a
complete picture of the judgment and
really we could say that the judgment is
separated in three phases with the third
really being the execution of the
Judgment so I'm just going to cover the
first two with you today so the first
part of the Judgment that takes place is
called the investigative judgment or the
pre-advent Judgment pre-advent meaning
uh a judgment before the second coming
of Christ and Daniel is given vision of
this in Daniel chapter 7 and9 and 10
where it says I beheld till the Thrones
were cast down and the Ancient of Days
meaning God did sit and in verse 10 the
Judgment or in the new King James it
says the court uh the judgment or the
court was set and the books were opened
now here's God at sitting over
essentially this courtroom setting if
you will and then so also you read in
who is going to be judged in Romans
chapter 14 where it says for we shall
all stand before the Judgment seat of
Christ and in verse 12 so then each of
us shall give an account of himself to
God so it is Us in this pre-advent
judgment that is being judged by God now
again in this courtroom setting we have
to have an attorney or a lawyer so in 1
John 2:1 we are told that we have an
advocate with the father Christ Jesus
the righteous so Jesus also being our
attorney and our mediator and lastly uh
John 5 and verse 22 it says for the
father judges no one but has committed
all judgment to the son now at this
point judgment has been made the court
has been settled and um those who have
been deemed righteous now have been
called up to heaven you can read that in
1 Thessalonians 4: 16-1 17 as well as 1
Corinthians chap 15 and:
51-53 now those who are called to Heaven
still have a part to play in the
judgment and this is where the other
part of your question comes in now
during the Thousand-Year reign in heaven
which you can read about in Revelation
chap 20 in Revelation 20 verse4 John the
Revelator says and I in vision and I saw
in Thrones and they sat on them meaning
they the Saints and judgment was
committed to them and this is also
reestablished by what Paul says in 1
Corinthians chapter 6 6 and verse 2 and
3 where it says do you not know that the
Saints will judge or decide the world
and if the world will be judged are you
unworthy to judge the smallest matters
do you not know that we shall judge
Angels so now the saints that are spoken
of here in 1 Corinthians chapter 6 are
all the saved throughout history whom
Christ takes to Heaven at his second
coming and this will take uh part in the
second phase of the Judgment now imagine
when you get to heaven though that
you're going to have some questions and
why is this person here and not this and
and vice versa or this person now this
part of the judgment is going to provide
all of those answers for you the saved
are going to review the lives of every
lost person to include Satan and his
angels and will agree with Jesus's
decisions about each person's Eternal
fate and it will be clear of those who
either um accepted Jesus and to serve
him or rejected him wow wow well
done a lot to say in a few words yeah
just little bit Shelly your second
question MH will we still be able to
pray to our good Lord Jesus once
probation is closed and the spirit of
Our Lord withdraws from the earth and
this is from zelia zela I just am so
glad that you sent this question in
because there's some people that feel
they have unnecessary concerns let me
let me just say this before the great
flood God warned in Genesis 63 he said
my spirit will not strive with man
forever so a day is coming again when
the Holy Spirit will quit striving with
evil people he will cease striving to
working to lead them to repentance and
at that point when he ceases working on
them because he knows there's not any
point then he will cease restraining
even on the earth so people will have
made their decisions for or against God
as a final decision and that's when
probation closes Revelation 21 or 2211
said Jesus says he is unjust let him be
unjust still he who is filthy let him be
filthy still this is after that
investigative judgment he already knows
whose names is in the Book of Life he
who is righteous let him be righteous
still he is Holy let him be holy still
so the Destinies are fixed there's no
possibility of change but now in 2
Thessalonians 2:7 here's where your
questions coming in the mystery of
lawlessness is already at work only he
who now
restrains will do so until he is taken
out of the way the holy spirit's work
think about this what is his main work
it's
convicting and restraining evil this
will cease he is going to step aside and
when he does this primarily affects the
unrepentant they'll be unchecked and
manifest their Rebellion against God but
God Still Remains intimately connected
with his faithful children he will still
live in our hearts and through faith by
the power of the Holy Spirit he's not
taking the holy spirit away from you you
he has said in Hebrews 13:5 I will never
leave you nor forsake you so in
Revelation 7 1-4 we see that God's
covenant people are sealed before the
close of probation so after the close of
probation we don't need a mediator
because we we've already been declared
righteous our sins are blotted out our
Salvation is assured and this does not
mean that prayer will be meaningless we
still will need that vital Lifeline to
him we can still pray and ask him for
strength to get through that Jacob's
time of trouble during those final days
and our prayers will just be focused a
little differently will be focused on
Deliverance and asking him for strength
and Trust during the final crisis and we
can trust that he will still hear an
answer Psalm
91:15 he says he shall call upon me and
and I will answer him I'll be with him
in trouble I will deliver him and honor
him prayers during this time will
reflect our deep dependence on God for
the strength and the courage and the
deliverance and we will know that his
promises to hear and answer prayer will
still remain sure good good want to take
just one second here two seconds maybe
and repeat our contact list if you want
to text 618 228
3975 if you'd like to email that's Bible
QA
3abn.org
sick and this is from yiel in Porto Rico
all right I'm excited about this
question and answer a short and to the
point question but the answer will take
a little bit longer now Jesus could get
sick because he was a person he was
human he was born with a human body
after 4,000 years of the degradation
that had come as a result of sin he
breathed the same tainted air that
everybody else breathed he drank the
same water that had become polluted by
the things that sin had done and he ate
of the same plants that grew out of the
soil that had grown contaminated because
of sin and it's gotten much worse since
that day 4,000 years ago some time
that's why Paul writes in Hebrews 2:17
therefore in all things he had to be
made like his Brethren Jesus walked the
same path that we walked with the same
things available to him but you're going
to be excited to know because Jesus is
your example you'll be excited to know
that Jesus was never sick and here's
what the Bible has to say about that let
me give you a five reason from the Bible
number one when we go back to
Deuteronomy chapter 28 it's the the
chapter of blessings and curses says
there are blessings if you diligently
obey the voice of the Lord your God and
one of those blessings includes health
and then there are curses if you do not
obey the voice of the Lord your God
including disease and illness and you'll
see those as you read through that
chapter Jesus did only what pleased the
father he was only obedient from moment
one that there was nothing that could
come to him that would be a curse in
fact Proverbs 26:2 says that a curse
Without a Cause can not come Jesus did
nothing that could bring a curse those
curses could not come to him he could
only experience the
blessings reason number two is Exodus
15:26 that says if you diligently heed
the voice of the Lord your God and do
what is right in his sight give ear to
his Commandments and keep all his
statutes I will put none of the diseases
on you which I have brought on the
Egyptians for I am the Lord who heals
you this is an actual promise of God
this isn't flowery ornamental language
just to hang on your wall and think is
beautiful this is a promise of God and
Jesus he did not finally turn to
Obedience of God after years of
rebellion where he had the residual
effects of sin Jesus only obeyed the
father he followed God way perfectly his
whole life and in his experience Jesus
proved that God is righteous and
faithful and he keeps his
promises reason number three there are
numerous texts that you'll find them in
Exodus through Deuteronomy that told
that the sacrifices that represented
Jesus were to be without blemish
Deuteronomy 17:1 if you want to go look
at one of those all right the the
sacrifices representing Jesus
unblemished Now 1 Peter 1: 18 and 19
says you were not redeemed with
corruptible things like silver or gold
from your aimless conduct received by
tradition from your fathers but with the
precious blood of Christ as of a lamb
without blemish and spot so Jesus was
unblemished no spot in him definitely
morally but also physically because he
was perfectly obedient to the father
there was nothing that had marked
what God had placed what who he was
nothing within him experienced Decay
nothing in within him experienced
corruption Isaiah 63:9 says in all their
Affliction he was afflicted so Jesus
bore our sin and he bore our sickness
but he did not have sin or its
consequences in himself they were not
within him instead his very presence
rebuked sickness and rebuked illness and
then reason number four I love this text
it's Psalm 16:10 speaking prophetically
of Jesus Psalm 16:10 says for you will
not leave me in shaol that's the grave
nor will you allow your Holy One to see
corruption now when this text is quoted
in Acts 2:31 and acts 13:34 it's very
clear that the apostles were using this
text to refer to Decay physical decay in
the grave
so if Jesus dead body did not Decay and
all the sins of the world were placed
upon him but he committed no sins and
his dead body did not Decay then we know
that his living body did not Decay
because of sin his living body did not
see corruption finally let me leave you
with third John verse 2 chapter 1 only
chapter beloved I pray that you may
prosper in all things and be in health
just as your soul prospers this is an
inspired prayer prompted by the Holy
Spirit which represents God's will for
the people who follow him and Jesus was
always in God's will in absolutely
everything and so even in what he ate
even in when he ate and so Jesus
experienced that Health that was prayed
for see food does not sustain your life
and health even though God bids us to
eat the food that he gives that He
blesses God Alone sustains our life
especially when we obey him and allow
him to Jesus ate the food on Earth but
he was sustained by the father in
perfect health because he was perfectly
in line with God's will that's a
blessing and that reminds us that his
example is one that we can follow amen
great great answer Ian the third
question if someone has an attraction to
people of the same sex but doesn't
physically act on it are they still
sinning by just having a samex raction
and this is from Tim all right Tim uh
thank you for your question I'm actually
going to counter your question with
another question by saying now for me
having attraction to the opposite sex
and I don't act on it am I still sinning
now whether it's same sex or not really
doesn't make a difference and let me
explain the Bible is very clear
regarding homosexual acts which you can
find in 1 Corinthians chapter 6 and
verses 9-10 and it says that those in
engage in them uh will not inherent the
kingdom of God now similarly those in
those that's in 1 Corinthians chapter 6
it says that the same passages are clear
that Those who commit adultery or
fornication having the same fate as that
of Those who commit homosexual acts so
the attraction in and of itself is not a
sin but it does not have to just be
physical as your question suggested we
read it in Matthew 5 and verse 28 that
says but I say to you that whoever looks
at a woman to Lust For Her has already
committed adultery with her in his heart
and the same could be said for same-sex
attraction so are you lusting over this
person are you having impure thoughts
over that person are you dwelling on it
for too long we're told in Proverbs 23
and: 7 says for as he thinketh in his
heart so is he so this really just
brings up the question then between
Temptation and sin now being tempted in
and of itself is not a sin either we all
are going to face Temptations throughout
our Christian Life and Jesus himself
faced Temptations which you can read
about in Matthew chapter 4 now we're
also told in Hebrews chapter 4 that
Jesus was in all points tempted as we
are yet without sin so we are given uh
encouragement when we are faced with
these Temptations and one of my favorite
books of the Bible is James chapter 1
and in James chapter 1: 2-4 it says my
brethren count it all joy when ye fall
into diverse Temptations knowing this
that the trying of your faith worketh
patience but let patience have her
perfect work that ye may be perfect and
entire wanting nothing it is what we do
when Temptation comes our way and in
this case same seex attraction now James
goes on to tell us in a few verses later
in James chapter 1 in verse 14 he says
but each one is tempted when he is drawn
away from his own desires and enticed
and that's where it needs to stop the
temptation but it continues on and says
then when desire has conceived it gives
birth to sin and sin when it is foreg
grown brings forth death now there is a
saying by a man that you may have heard
of um the saying goes sin will take you
farther than you want to go keep you
longer than you want to stay and cost
you more than you want to pay and the
man that's actually credited with saying
this things were were revealed about him
and the struggles that he also had so he
very well knows about what he's speaking
about now Temptation what that does
though is it provides us an opportunity
for spiritual conquest and growth so it
is not a disgrace or a sin to be tempted
because without battles there can be no
Victory uh in James 1 and verse 10 or
verse 12 blessed is the man that
endureth Temptation for when he is tried
he shall receive the Crown of Life which
the Lord hath promised to them that love
him so it's not just a physical act be
mindful of the physical but also by the
mental and again just to reiterate same
sex attraction in and of itself is not a
sin it is what you do with it when that
Temptation comes is what matters amen
amen good answer Shelly your third
question why do we have to suffer for
something that Eve did and this is from
Cheryl Cheryl actually we're not
suffering from what Eve did we're
suffering from what Adam did Eve was
deceived and when she ate the fruit she
thought she was doing the right thing
yes she shared it with her husband but
the Bible says in 1 Timothy 2:14 Adam
was not deceived he ate knowing it was
the wrong thing to do and when he did he
fell into transgression and he was the
human representative the Covenant Son of
God the human representative and the
Bible tells us in Acts 17:26 we're all
made from one blood we ended up
inheriting his his Fallen nature Romans
5:18 and 19 says as through one man's
offense he's speaking of Adam judgment
came to all men resulting in
condemnation even so through one man's
righteous act speaking of Jesus the free
gift came to all resulting in
justification of life for as by one
man's Disobedience Adam many were made
Sinners so also by one man's obedience
many will be made righteous you know
Romans 3:23 most everybody knows this
all of sin and fall short of the glory
of God but they stop it goes forward
saying being justified freely by his
grace through the Redemption that is in
Christ Jesus so 1 Corinthians
15:45 talks about the first Adam and the
last at him Jesus is the new
representative of humankind and we know
that Romans 5:17 says if by the one
man's offense death Reign through the
one much more those who receive an
abundance of grace and the gift of
righteousness will reign in life through
the one Christ Jesus amen very good very
good Daniel your fourth question will
Satan or can Satan be destroyed and this
is from Grant in Trinidad and Tobago
thank you grant for asking this question
I sure hope so because I don't want him
hanging around for all of eternity
continuing to tempt and wreak havoc in
God's perfectly beautiful creation let
me tell you that no created being has
life within itself so that it can by its
own will perpetuate its life forever you
could say that created beings are
contingent beings that there existence
relies upon something else it's as if
we're on Divine life support that God
keeps us alive so even angels are
created beings so is Satan one of those
angels let's look in Ezekiel 28:4 and 15
now this is speaking about Lucifer
before his Rebellion when he became
Satan and the word Satan means adversary
and it tells us that he was a created
angel it says you were the anointed
cherub who covers I established you
that's creation language there you were
on the Holy Mountain of God you walked
back and forth in the midst of the fiery
Stones you were perfect in your ways
from the day you were created till
iniquity was found in you so Satan
Lucifer now Satan he is a contingent
being created by God on Divine life
support and that life support can be
removed now let's look specifically
where this happens in the Bible and
that's in Revelation 20:1
says the devil who deceived them was
cast into the lake of fire and brimstone
where the Beast and the false prophet
are as the Lake of Fire I don't know how
long he's going to survive in there but
it's not going to be forever and they
will be tormented day and night forever
and ever now this seems to actually
contradict what I just said and some
people are confused by this verse but
you have to look at all that the Bible
has to say on a topic to understand it
fully and we have a lot of resources let
me direct you uh here on 3abn things to
watch and read if you go to www 3abn
Bible
answers.com you're going to find answers
to a lot of questions including what is
meant by this text right here about
tormenting day and night forever and
ever but let me give you the brief
rundown many times in the Bible that
word forever it's a different word in
the Greek and the Hebrew it refers to
things that either will come to an end
or already have come to an end the Greek
word forever here what it means is that
it will continue without interruption
until it is complete so when will the
destruction of the wicked which will
continue without interruption at the
final destruction uh including Satan
when will that be complete When sin is
gone done no more and it's completely
consumed how do we know sin will be
consumed completely here's three texts
and there's many more Romans 623 three
says the wages of sin is death not
eternal life in a tortures chamber it is
death the gift of God is eternal life
all right Satan's not receiving the gift
of God he's not getting eternal life
somewhere else Revelation 20:4 says then
death and Hades were cast into the Lake
of Fire this is the second death death
comes to an end no more death and we
find that explicitly in Revelation 21:4
which tells us that in the new Heaven
and new Earth there shall be no more
death nor sorrow nor crying there shall
be no more pain for the former things
have passed away Eternal torture sounds
like pain there's going to be no more
pain all right so Satan will finally be
destroyed one more text to leave you
with John 3:16 you know it for God so
loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son that whoever believes in
him will not perish but have eternal
life and so you have two options Satan
will be taking the option of perishing
not eternal life praise the Lord amen
extremely
good andan your fourth question will God
still accept us into heaven if we
haven't overcome all our sins I struggle
with food addiction and I'm worried that
God will not accept me if he comes
tomorrow so to speak and this is from
Cecilia in Missouri all right Cecilia I
just want to say thank you though for
being open about your struggle and about
your addiction um and I've even
struggled with my own prior to becoming
a Christian and even as being a
Christian I've had my own uh struggles
with certain things but I'll be honest
with you that this uh question of yours
is a difficult one and uh there are
actually opinions on both sides of the
aisle regarding your question uh because
to overcome all of our sin before
Jesus's Second Coming would then imply
that we are to be perfect before he
comes and in fact in Matthew 5 and: 48
says therefore you shall be perfect just
as your father in Heaven is perfect now
this causes issu issues within the
Christian Community and it has obviously
brought you some distress as well
because of your addiction to the point
that you're worried on whether or not
God is going to accept you but we need
to look at the difference of of idea of
man's idea of perfection and overcoming
sin and what God's idea of uh Perfection
and overcoming sin because it's
interesting if you look at Genesis 6 and
ver9 God calls Noah a j man and perfect
in his Generations yet we know that
afterwards Noah drank alcoholic wine and
became drunk in First Kings 15 it says
that King ASA did that was right inside
of the Lord and that asa's heart was
perfect with the Lord all his days yet
ASA did not take down all the Pagan
places places of worship that was in the
land in Luke 1: 6 it says that Zacharias
and Elizabeth that they were both
righteous before God walking in all the
judgments and ordinances of the Lord
blameless yet later Zacharias became
mute for a period of time because of his
lack of faith so what do we do with this
how do we justify are we to be perfect
as uh is mentioned in Matthew 5: 48 and
overcome all of our sin before Jesus
comes now our focus should not
necessarily be on that we need to be
perfect from sin instead our focus
should be that we should be in perfect
submission to him am now if we are in
perfect submission to Jesus then we can
overcome all of our trials all of our
Temptations all of our struggles and all
of our sins Proverbs chapter 3 and verse
5 it says trust in the Lord with all of
your heart and lean not on your own
understanding in all of your ways
acknowledge Him and He Shall direct your
path and again in first or excuse me
second Peter chapter 1 and verse 4 it
says by which have been given to us
exceedingly great and precious promises
that through these you may be you may be
partakers of the divine nature having
escaped the corruption that is in the
world through lust so Cecilia as you or
anyone else that may be watching this as
you perfectly submit to Jesus we can
claim in one of my favorite verses I
have many but one of my favorite verses
is Romans 8 and: 37 that says yet in all
these things we are more than conquerors
through him who loved us so Cecilia or
anyone that's watching don't focus on
your Str
don't focus on when you fall don't focus
on your addiction but focus on Jesus
Christ and call out the same words that
Peter did out to Jesus and just say Lord
save me amen beauti help amen amen
Shelly your fourth question since Jesus
Took on human flesh and is no longer a
spirit like the father and the Holy
Spirit is he omnipresent or can he only
be in one place at a time and this is
from Rose Rosemary and Kenya Rosemary
this is a wonderful question and it's uh
something a lot of people don't know
when Jesus was resurrected he was
resurrected even though it was a
glorified body it was a real flesh and
Bone body he had scars in his hand he
had the hole from the spear uh in his
side in Luke 24:39 he said behold my
hands my feet this is that it is I
myself handle me and see for a spirit
does not have Flesh and Bones as you see
I have obviously he's speaking to Thomas
after the resurrection now he ascended
in that same flesh in he was fully human
fully Divine he ascended he he is the
new representative of mankind he is the
last Adam he is our high priest and when
he went up to heaven in Acts chapter 1
the Angels tell the disciples that are
gathered there men of Galilee why do you
stand gazing at Heaven this same Jesus
who was taken up from you into heaven
will so come in the like manner that you
saw him go so he's coming back in this
glorified flesh he sits at the right
hand of the Throne of the father right
now and he is our high priest we can see
that in Hebrews 8 1-2 it said this is
the main point of things we're saying we
have such a high priest who is seated at
the right hand of the Throne of majesty
in the heavens a minister of the
sanctuary and of the true Tabernacle
which the Lord erected and not man so
because he is in human form he can only
be in one place at one time it is he
said to his
disciples it's better that I depart they
didn't want him to depart but he said
it's better that I depart because he
said I'm going to send the Holy Spirit
who he called alos paracletos another
helper this is a person that's going to
walk beside them so he is
omnipresent through the holy spirit
because the godhead is one John 14:1
16-18 he said I will pray the father he
will give you alos pericos another
helper that means alos is one that's
just like me that he may abide with you
forever the spirit of Truth whom the
world cannot see receive because it
neither sees him or knows him but you
know him for he dwells in you and will
be with you I'll not leave you as
orphans so he says in John
16:7 I tell you the truth it's to your
advantage that I go away for if I do not
go away the helper will not come to you
but if I depart I will send him to you
when Jesus was on the earth he could
only be ministering to one disciple at a
time but now he's sent Theo he and the
father have sent the Holy Spirit and
Ephesians 3:16 through1 19 I love this
Paul says we pray that God would Grant
you according to the riches of his glory
to be strengthened with might through
his spirit in the Inner Man that Christ
May dwell in your hearts through faith
so when the holy spirit's in our heart
Christ is dwelling there that you can be
rooted and grounded in the love of God
so although Jesus is not
personally because he's fully Divine and
fully human he's not personally
omnipresent he took on this human flesh
he promised never to leave us or forsake
us he lives in our hearts by faith
through the Holy Spirit and his presence
is constantly with us amen thank youall
thank you'all thank youall we're just
going to take a short break here be back
in just a couple of minutes for closing
thoughts if you're enjoying our 3abn
Bible Q&A then tell your friends each
Monday we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God God's holy word to shed
light on those texts that seem difficult
to understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org Bible Q&A for answers from
God's word welcome back we're just going
to take a few minutes here and have
additional thoughts comments anybody
yeah I'd like to return to the music
question for just a moment because as I
whenever you evaluate your life
according to God's standards you start
to recognize that there's some things
that just little by little they don't
seem to fit and not just in the area of
music but all sorts of areas and we
start to sometimes think that God is
restricting us and we have to make these
sacrifices but I just want to encourage
you that it's a joyful thing to submit
your life to God just like Ian talked
about perfect submission to God and
little by little those things just don't
seem to fit and you're happy to let them
go so ask God to direct you in the next
steps that he would take you in all
areas of your life amen yeah and I just
like to say you know a lot of my
questions today dealt with judgment or
overcoming or addictions so what I would
want to leave you with is yet another
one of my favorite Bible verses which is
Philippians Ians 1:6 that says being
confident of this very thing that he who
has begun a good work in you will
complete it until the day of Jesus
Christ amen amen I just want to say on
the the best week of your life you are
no closer to God than the worst week of
your life so just remember that he loves
you that He is wanting to help you he's
not up there trying to watch for when
you make a mistake he's up there to
catch you when you fall MH and God loves
you he wants you to love him he wants
your heart so please if you've been
resisting the love of the lord we just
ask that you would invite him to become
your lord and savior I want to share
Isaiah
263 you will keep him in perfect peace
whose mind has stayed on you because he
trust you claim that just want to thank
you for spending this time with us we
love you take care
[Music]